hello everyone and welcome to the
continuation of the Riga interzone
Tournament of 1979 we've seen thousand
victory in round one it was a it was a
great one but now he faces a deadly
opponent it is a Soviet Grandmaster left
polyevsky uh who is not only one of the
strongest players in the world but also
has a a pretty good score against Tao
throughout their life they played 32
games style only won two of them uh
eight wins the polgeski and the 22 were
drawn and the previous game they played
some 20 years ago uh uh uh was the was
the one that tal won uh so the last time
Tom actually defeated polygouski was in
1959 and this is now 1979. but like I
said this is tournament so let's see
what happened in this one and probably
the reason why uh polgesky had such a
great score against tall is because he
understood how to play against style uh
some of you might not know this but from
1950 to 1953 uh Paul gaski was training
with none other than the greater Rashid
Nish medinov and three years offending
Golf and Edge Medina's attacks will
prepare you for for anything coming your
way even a great attacker like Tao so
let's see what happened in this one uh
we have Knight to F3 by pologevsky and
tal goes for Pawn to C5 sort of a
sillion invitation if I plays E4 then we
just play the Sicilian but uh left plays
C4 uh he transposes into the English
opening Knight to F6 with Knight to C3
and now Pawn to D5 striking in the
center C captures Knight captures and
now Ponte E4 with Knight to be four by
tal now going for that D3 square and
just Bishop the C4 he's not worried
about Knight to D3 check it's uh in fact
it's the top move that you can play in
the position but now actually goes for
Bishop to E6 it's a very tricky line
that invites Bishop captures on E6 which
will mess up your Pawn structure but you
will get the place a knight on D3 on a
post so let's see what happens Bishop
captures an E6 uh live except Styles
challenge Knight of the D3 check King to
F1 and now F captures an E6 we have
knighted to G5 now he goes after the E6
Pawn as well Queen to B6 style defense
while developing his Queen and also you
really have to worry about C4 once C4
lands not only is your knight on D3
defended but also Tao will be
threatening Checkmate on F2 which is
pretty crazy it's only Moon 9 and okay
Queen to E2 and it is not as of move 10
that we have a completely new game
topless C4 now the Knight is defended
and also that Queen cannot uh leave just
anywhere she needs to defend the F2 Pawn
B3 of course he wants to charge the C4
Pawn to get rid of the Knight and here
top plays H6 we have Knight back to F3
and now uh if you're wondering about
Queen to H5 check there's really no
reason to play that just King the D7 and
now you have to worry about your Knight
hanging and also Checkmate on F2 so uh
yes okay you can play Knight to H3 this
kind of takes care of both threads but
still it's a very shaky position for
white so instead Knight back to F3 uh by
Lev and now comes Knight to C6 style
figures he's just gonna give up one more
Pawn on C4 and he's gonna play Knight to
C6 and castles and then the Rook will
come to d8 to defend the Knight and the
Knight can stay there so it's a very
very nice trade-off B captures on C4 we
have Queen side Castles by tal and now
Pawn to G3 and this is a pretty much the
first sub-optimal move from left but the
position is incredibly complicated now
the way you want to play this is either
by playing Knight to D5 which is a weird
move to play and also Knight the E1 uh
sorry Knights the E1 those are your
moves that you want to play I'm just
gonna quickly show you what happens now
you disconnect the Rook from the Knight
and you are threatening Queen captures
on D3 but still after he captures Queen
captures on D3 and Knight B4 attacking
the queen it's not easy to play this
let's say queen to E3 You're Gonna Play
Queen to C7 now Knights the C2 is coming
it's a very very difficult position to
play but of course you could play it the
other one is Knight the E1 let's just
get rid of the knight from D3 then
Knight captures an E1 now a nice Vision
Suga Rook to B1 attacking thous queen
queen to A5 and only now King captures
on E1 let's say Knight to D4 attacks the
queen and now Queen to D1 and still your
king is an E1 you will have to spend a
few more moves to Castle artificially
but you can play this however after G3
here uh polkavski really wants
everything he he captured some material
he wants to play King to G2 and then
bring the Rook into the game uh but I
mean that's that's just too much style
now plays G5 with King to G2 and now
Queen to C5 by tal going after the C4
Pawn uh We've rooked the B1 and now
Bishop to G7 just nicely developing
pieces with Knight to B5 and now comes
Queen captures on C4 giving up the C4
Pawn with the idea that now the queen
can come to E3 and you can put pressure
along this diagonal but it doesn't work
Queen captures on C4 by tall we have
Queen to E3 and now Rook H to f8 putting
pressure on that f file uh and here uh
how do you continue this in the game
Rook def one was played uh kind of
trying to
and our Defender did it F2 Pawn uh the
problem is if you go for Knight captures
an A7 check which of course you can uh
this is what happens Knight captures
Queen captures an A7 and now Queen
captures an E4 and how do you defend the
Knight on F3 you have to bring the queen
back Queen to E3 and not just Queen D5
you keep that pressure here of course
you're not gonna trade and now G4 is
coming and the only way to stop uh any
uh severe material loss is H3 but then
just H5 preparing G4 and now you have to
play Rook to B3 it's your only option G4
H captures H captors Rook captures on D3
and now G captures on F3 comes with
check that's kind of the problem Queen
captures and now Queen captures on D3
and after only seven done captures
captures uh tal will be up a full Rook
so that's why it doesn't work even
though uh it does look like it should
work kind of bust the bust open the
black queen side but not really so Rook
to F1 was played by uh by polgevsky and
now Pawn to G4 by top with Knight to H4
and now there are many good moves here
like you could even consider a nice Pawn
grab with Queen captures and A2 and some
of you I'm sure would go for that uh if
you enjoy grabbing material but not tall
tall plays Knight captures on F2 and
this now position is so complicated not
only because it's complicated but
because there's no way out the position
is completely winning for tal although
it does seem like you you could maybe
defend uh so just to give you an example
of what happens after Rook captures on
F2 the idea is Rook captures an F2 check
King captures uh if you capture with the
queen then you allow Queen captures and
E4 check nicely connects with the rook
and B1 so you were gonna you're gonna
have to play King captures now Rook the
f8 with Chuck King to G2 and now let's
say
uh Queen to F1 with Checkmate so there's
really not much point in in capturing
this Knight so after Knight captures an
F2 poladevski tried Knight to G6 but now
although it's a very nice move there is
a winning uh way for tal but there's
only one way to win this so feel free to
pause the video and figure out the best
way to do this while I give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible uh maneuver and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook to D3 this is the the only
way to do it there are other good moves
but this is just absolutely crushing and
the reason for that is that the only two
options that the polkavsky really has uh
don't really work and uh we're just
gonna go through through some of them
like what what happens if Knight
captures an E7 is that an idea uh kind
of getting this Knight out of the way
maybe putting pressure on A7 the problem
is if you go for this uh just King the
D7 Tau will not capture Tao will play
King to D7 and now let's say Knight A3
you attack the queen queen to A6 just
keeps the keeps the tension the White
Queen is still hanging and once you play
Queen C5 now comes Rook D to F3 which is
the original idea behind Rook to D3
doubling up on the f file and now after
Queen B5 yes you can trade Queens but
let's say captures and captures uh now
comes Knight to the D3 and here you
resign then 97 is hanging and also the
Rook on F1 is saying if you first
capture then you can capture with the
pawn with check then pick up the Knight
so white loses a heavy material here
another uh reason uh uh why it's
completely lost is that if you go Queen
to E1 you just want to move the queen
Here Comes Rook D to F3 again and now
after Knight to A3 hoping that a rook
capture so you can capture the Knight on
F2 You're Gonna Play Queen to A4 and now
what do you do uh it's uh pretty bad if
Knight captures an f8 then again Knight
to D3 attacks the queen and also puts
pressure on The Rook here if Queen E2
then Knight the D4 attacks the queen
once again and the ones the queen moves
and offers a trade now you trade Queen
captures Rook captures and Rook to have
to check King wherever let's say King to
H1 and now Knights the F3 with uh uh
imminent Checkmate on the next move Rook
captures on H2 is Unstoppable so that's
what would happen if you went a queen to
E1 and the Really uh from those two
options there really isn't anything uh
pologevsky tried Knights the A3 sort of
a different move order but still Queen
T4 by tall now Queen to E1 and I'll just
plays Rook D to F3 similar to the line
that we've shown Knight captures on f8
he even grabs The Rook but now Knights
the D3 uh like we've shown Queen to D1
and now tal even captures an E4 Queen
captures an E4 now threatening very
nasty discoveries so a capture on F3 is
a must Rook captures with Pawn captures
with check King to F1 and now Queen to
F5 Queen to G4 also was playable you
want to play Queen to H3 with check so
King to G1 and now comes Bishop to D4
with check and he was in this position
and move 28 that left polgreensky
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so a true tactical
Masterpiece by tal winning his second
game in a row in the ariga in the zonal
tournament of 1979. uh so here you
resign because after King H1 uh you you
can do anything you can play Knight
checks you can play Pawn to F2 but you
don't even have to take the queen it's
much cooler if you don't let the king G1
Knight the E for checking H1 Knight
captures on G3 with check and we reach
the position from the thumbnail with a
nice Checkmate you can play Queen F3 H3
Checkmate you can play Queen to H5
Checkmate I prefer Queen to H5 so that's
the one we're gonna show uh so yeah very
nicely done by tal and uh like I said
the polygouski had a brilliant score
against Dal and um uh as this was 1979
they were playing to qualify for the
candidates tournament both tal and
polugowski qualified for the candidates
tournament and uh in the in the
quarterfinals of the uh of the
candidates matches apollovsky eliminated
style uh without uh winning a single
game final final score was something
like five and a half to two and a half
like three three wins for polgievsky
zero wins for tall and five draws so uh
pretty pretty uh amazing result and it's
what um stopped tal on his next World
cheers Championship run basically and
Paul guys also had great chances but he
lost a very very tough match in the
semi-finals the Victor korchnoy Victor
the terrible and it was it was a very
close matchup let me just check I don't
want to trick you guys uh do I have the
results somewhere I had him somewhere I
think I don't anymore
yeah I'm sorry I don't I don't have them
here but I think it was like something
like uh uh like six six and a half to uh
seven and a half like uh Victor one by
by one point margin uh but yeah uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh tall second and last victory against
the great left poluseki I hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank BB
chess London system Kevin Olive Marco
still and Stefan Cornell for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day